if it had the potential to perform as
well as 2017's it's and the upcoming
Shazam Fury of the Gods why didn't that
girl get his chance in the theaters
there's one fact that no dceu fan can
ever dispute this universe has changed
course and Direction more signs and Dom
Toretto does in a fast and furious movie
whenever it appears as if a blueprint
has laid out for filmmakers to follow
some ancillary events happens and
everything is flipped on his head in the
case of bad girl the original intention
was reportedly to introduce her in the
film Universe earlier through 2020's
Birds of Prey in the comics Barbara
Gordon was a founding member of this
team along with the Black Canary however
the remaining members often differed or
were rotated out yet in the film
adaptation Babs was nowhere to be found
great
most like other DC films Birds of Prey
went through several changes and
switched a ruse before Kathy Yan hopped
on board as a director in the end Babs
didn't make the cut for the team
possibly also due to the fact that no
one knew who the main Batman of the dceu
was at the time making it a bit tricky
to introduce her the film's producer Sue
Kroll deferred heroic Hollywood's
question about why Batgirl wasn't
introduced in Birds of Prey to Warner
Brothers Kroll said this is a studio
question that characters and
developments on her own film right the
name just Whedon isn't particularly
popular in Hollywood or among the DC
fandom these days while the filmmaker
achieved record-breaking Success With
The Avengers for Marvel he didn't quite
bring the same to Justice League the
theatrical cut of the movie was
described as something of a
Frankenstein's monster via the rap as
his and original director Zack Snyder's
Vision didn't mesh well at all after the
whole Justice League Fiasco Whedon was
still supposed to carry on playing in
the DC EU as a writer and director for
basket girl something that raised more
than a few eyebrows however he Departed
the project in 2018 when pressed about
the reasons for leaving Whedon told
variety the story kind of just crumbled
in my hands there were elements that I
just hadn't mastered that after a long
time felt like I wasn't going to I told
people that I didn't have an idea which
isn't an exact truth I had an idea but
it didn't fit in the space that was left
for it but several years after that a
number of allegations about whedon's
Behavior towards the Justice League cast
spun out in the public sphere the
filmmaker eventually responded to the
criticism but he is still Persona on
grata in the DC film universe even
though Batgirl had been in development
for several years Leslie Grace wasn't
cast as Barbara Gordon until 2021
according to deadline naturally fans
spent a lot of time debating who should
play the Beloved bat family member with
Jane Levy being a name constantly
brought up in conversations in fact the
actor even used her Twitter account to
throw her name into the ring and drum up
some excitement for herself in the end
though the decision was between grace
and the White Lotus actor Hayley Lou
Richardson in an interview at The
Hollywood Reporter Richardson opened up
about the experience and about losing
out on the role she said I really tried
let me tell you I did get a nice little
personal email from JK Simmonds out of
it which was really nice getting the
role would have been pretty cool but I
told myself that his email meant more to
me than getting the role of course
Simmons reprized his Justice League role
as Jim Gordon Batgirl's father in the
film the Warner Brothers Discovery deal
had a huge impact on the DC Universe
News of the merger have been in the
pipeline for a while and it created
turbulence around the state of the dceu
since a regime change was on the horizon
and no one knew what the future held
there were Standalone films like Matt
Reeves the Batman and Todd Phillips
Joker but the status quo of the dceu was
always uncertain considering how plans
were subject to change at the drop of a
hat
fans found this whole scenario confusing
they weren't the only ones as it turns
out the filmmakers involved in these
projects also had no idea what was going
on but girl directors Adele lrb and
Bilal falar explained to the director
they weren't told which Universe their
film was set in lrb said we would also
ask oh you have JK Simmons from the
snyderverse and we got Michael Keaton
from the Burton verse what's the
situation there and they would say don't
worry about it we got a plan they never
really explained that aspect to us what
are the odds that Warner Brothers wasn't
sure about that either
the streaming walls are still upon us
and there seems to be no end in sight as
various platforms compete for similar
audiences and their subscriptions the
only way to win this battle is for the
streamers to provide the sorts of
content that viewers demand for HBO Max
the solution was to make platform
exclusive films like Batgirl as per The
Hollywood Reporter well the film didn't
have an Avengers like budget of 250
million dollars plus it still costly
reported 90 million dollars to produce
according to the rap entertainment
reporters Eric Davis and Umberto
Gonzalez held a session on Twitter
spaces where they discussed further
details about the movie according to
Gonzalez a source described a bad girl
as looking like something the CW would
have produced he recalled a source of
mindset I saw Batgirl certainly not the
worst superhero movie but ultimately I
understand why they canceled it I asked
this individual to elaborate a little
further and was told it's basically
essentially an expensive CW pilot which
is what I heard it was well that might
not be what fans wanted to hear about
film there's also no disputing that the
CW's arrowverse was a hit with audiences
even if it didn't feature a massive
budget Hollywood is like a Boulevard of
Broken Dreams it sells fantasies then
rips them away just as they're about to
come true since there is always a chance
that something will be canceled in the
pre-production phase most people in the
film industry don't believe anything
until it officially enters production
and the crew is on site bad girl however
proved to be one of the greatest
anomalies in the history of the business
Not only was 90 million dollars spent on
the film but it was also deep in
post-production before it received the
ax according to the Hollywood Reporter
the studio issued the following
statement about the cancellation the
decision to not release but girl
reflects our leadership strategic shift
as it relates to the DC Universe and HBO
Max it also helped the studio receive a
significant tax write-off as it embarked
on a cost-cutting exercise nonetheless
it shocked the world as no one has seen
such a high profile project get canceled
so close to the finish line an unnamed
exec from a rival Studio told film
reporter Justin Kroll that it was
something they'd never seen in 30 years
in the business the decision by Warner
Brothers Discovery to cancel Bagel
blindsided everyone especially since the
film was practically complete and as
part of a popular multimedia franchise
however many rumors have since surfaced
about what happened behind the scenes
that led to the movie's cancellation
including poor test screening scores
according to the New York Post the film
wasn't well received by test audiences
at all and the studio feared that
releasing the film would have been
irredeemable in the long run instead
Warner Brothers Discovery decided to hit
the eject button and ensure bad girl
would never be seen by moviegoers if you
won't let me help you what else can I do
and that said there have been
conflicting reports about the purported
low test scores The Hollywood Reporter
suggested that the film had only been
tested once in front of an audience and
received a rating in the low 60s which
would put it on par with other films
such as 2017's it and the upcoming
Shazam a fury of the Gods it was also
still without all its special effects
and the bells and whistles of a final
cut so the people in attendance would
have been watching a work in progress
rather than a completed version of the
film when Warner Brothers Discovery
pulled the plug on Batgirl it would seem
that the right thing to do would have
been to call up the casting crew and
explain the reasons that way they would
have all been prepared for when the news
broke in the media and all the questions
were fired in their Direction
unfortunately that wasn't the path the
studio chose leaving the crew just a
surprise by the film's cancellation as
everyone else I can't believe this
happening according to critical room the
crew was reportedly informed by the
studio to stop working on the film and
wait for further instructions however
the very next day they found out that
bad girl was canceled via social media
at the same time as everyone else
considering all the work they had done
on the movie and with no indication that
a cancellation was in the cards this
must have been the worst kind of
surprise for everyone who poured their
blood sweats and tears into the project
as soon as the news was officially
announced that bad girl was done for
there was a somberness in the air both
from fans and the people who worked on
the film The Sadness rippled across
social media as it felt like the loss of
a loved one or friend Batgirl was dead
and buried and nothing was going to
bring this film back from the grave to
close out the Saga Warner Brothers
Discovery reportedly held a screening
for the cast and crew and officially
dubbed the funeral screening according
to the Hollywood Reporter it allowed
everyone who was involved with the movie
one last chance to see the project that
they had worked so hard on after the
film was shown it was locked away in the
archives never to be discussed or seen
again it would be interesting to find
out if everyone wore black to the events
and brought Reese after the drama of
Zack Snyder's Justice League and the
vocal fandom that publicly targeted
Warner Brothers the studio was forced to
move in the direction of the release of
the Snyder cut but it didn't seem like
Warner Brothers was in the mood for
round two of that whole ordeal for
Batgirl as soon as the news broke that
the film was canceled the fans started
to rally on Twitter to see if they could
get another movement going to save
Barbara Gordon's Solo movie
unfortunately it appears as if the
studio wised up from the last time and
prevented the directors from even
teasing the possibility of it happening
in the future speaking to Entertainment
Weekly Adil el-abi and Bilal falal
confirmed that the film couldn't be
released as is since it required a few
more pickup shots and the addition of
visual effects however they wouldn't be
able to do so even if they wanted to
because they were logged out of
accessing the footage fala said we have
nothing Adele called me and said go
ahead and shoot some things on your cell
phone I went on the server and
everything was blocked it sounds like
Warner Brothers isn't messing around and
bad girl isn't Gonna See the Light of
day at least not any day soon
[Music]